and Steven I know it's it's been the the
it's draining the restraining order has
finally been lifted we can talk again
thanks what happened between you two I
heard rumors uh no I didn't know well
I'm glad it's all resolved right it's
great it's great to see you uh I want to
start with I've seen the first two
episodes cannot wait to watch the rest
um and I'm curious for both of you
everything that Taylor Sheridan touches
like turns into a huge hit what do you
think it is about
um his writing and his world and I know
this was done with Terence winter but
you know what is it about his work that
resonates with so many people it's a
great question I mean it's enigmatic
almost uh for for me for my stance is uh
you know at a time when we're completely
deconstructed what television is it's
streaming it's you know no two people
are watching the same thing these days
but he has this uh incredible herbal
ability to create and Galvanize an
audience I you know it's it's remarkable
um and I I guess if people knew the
secret sauce there'd be more people
doing it but there aren't I mean he's
really uh he's got an incredibly hot
hand it's about authenticity
authentically unbelievably exploring the
mystery of The Human Condition not
everybody can do that a lot of times
things are a little uh but he's spot on
with that so I think that's what draws
audiences to his projects is the
authenticity of exploring The Human
Condition the mystery of being a human
being for both of you
um no one has seen the show yet so can
you sort of talk about who you play and
how you interact with Stallone uh I
guess I'll start uh I'm play Vince
antonacci who's a capo in the invernessi
family who uh is home by AC here and
peed in Bernice and um I I see Vince as
a product of inheritance he's is uh
someone who is an incredible quality to
spend time with the boss's son
um you know he's a representative of the
decline of what the mafia once was and
uh is taking uh uh his privilege uh with
him and um and his relationship with
Stallone is very adversarial because
Stallone you know back in to say it was
one of the people that carved out this
racket that I have now inherited and uh
with him getting out of prison it's a
great risk to what I have uh will I you
know you know he could easily make a
claim of title and territory and uh
that's a threat to me
foreign
[Music]
he's got an alligator smile you know
nice grin but he'll he'll eat you alive
and stab you in the back and do anything
he needs to do to control and maintain
that power a deceptive individual who
seems like he's completely honest
for soon to be fans of this show and
believe me there are soon to be fans
what do you think would surprise people
to learn about the actual making of the
show behind the scenes the biggest
surprise I think behind making it is the
uh the love that the the the cast and
crew really shared I mean all of us
being away in this incredibly spare
environment and some of the locations
that we had to shoot we really had each
other so there was a lot of time spent
extracurricular time where I think we
got to know each other and I think the
surprise will be how much work was
behind the work that
ends up on screen
and a lot of laughs a lot of laughter
yeah that's right
um listen I know there's going to be a
big hit I'm going to say congrats to
both of you and good luck with the rest
of your speed dating
hey thanks be there great seeing you man
thanks great seeing you have a great day